[Music]
and still got it news submitted by your
mom's an 85 year old retired clergyman
now enjoys mind-blowing sex in his new
life as a porn star
what's a clergyman Lord O Lord to the
sport I think yeah men of the Lord yeah
yeah so it seems like he's not a
Catholic priest because they do mention
that he was married for 28 years maybe a
pastor yeah something like that so so
yeah so now he's doing why didn't the
[ __ ] that's such a 180 right he was
watching old people porn a lot of people
we would've [ __ ] up put your finger
here like that actually have you ever
heard of Bobby Lee no all the time he
will he likes to watch grandpa's [ __ ]
young that's what I was gonna say yeah
milah I used to like that grandma
I'm over it where are you serious don't
be asking like no I like things that
were so disgusting that I wouldn't want
to do I still like like gangbangs I
would never want to do a gang thing yeah
okay but like I like watching him so you
use the watch you so much older man with
younger girls yeah yeah especially like
you just said no porn shaving huh yeah
that like our chick oh yeah
but young don't know I said porn shame
let her change here's like the norm and
then Mickey comes in no do you know I
don't want to get [ __ ] by your old man
but that's not weird it's just like so
like I like that I honestly think it
just makes a lot of sense thank you it's
the sugar daddy experience things that
he go oh no but she has to do you know
but like I really like being totally
dominated right and it's like and even
like Steve and I and role play it's like
no I can't I have a boyfriend you know
it's like but I have to take his dick
you know and so it'll so like that was
kind of like fulfilled that for me where
it's like you know you would never with
that guy but you have to do Madden
Steve's all like old men cosplay just
the hair back here you do it
yeah probably it was like oh he's my
boss he owns the company and like I need
a raise but is 85 yeah but like what
what if I needed I needed the money cuz
I have to support a child on my own you
need a lot of backstory that maybe like
luck if I had to have all that and then
like this was my only option and I gotta
take it even though it's gross yeah
you're like the complete opposite of
maybe because I'm so [ __ ] superficial
and any little flaw oh yeah in the body
that's like what [ __ ] latex porn i
might cover it all up like oh that's
lucky you married an asian s he's never
gonna wrinkle until he's like 85 like
not a freckle on your arm no no we're
like girl
nothing not that I wanted my watch you
[ __ ] dolphin skin that's funny
wait so did you see like hella old like
to see old saggy balls and that was in
yeah and they're like some of them they
didn't even have a big dick it was just
like a girl she probably wasn't liking
it I liked but it was like he was really
liking it I was like oh she had to I'm
like yeah give it give her that ring I
watched a gangbang before I watch that
well now that's a my haven't watched
that kind of porn in it since I was like
20 maybe yeah well let me hear about
this right yeah let's hear about this
grandpa oh this grandpa was interviewed
for a documentary series that's called
Oh a PS on the game Oh bus the sex
business so APA it's a person who's old
enough to receive old-age pension
senior citizen center branding that was
old age penetration hahahaha
I thought you were going to say no I'd
like the British way of calling people
like the elder the elderly geriatric a
pensioner pensioner yeah it's a pension
is like you get paid money when you're
old like senior citizens yeah so that's
what this documentaries are out so if
they should call it Papa penis or
something like that well it's not just
for men because they do interview like
granny's I know in this next industry
too there was a documentary in that in
Britain about like the red-light
district or something and then in Europe
and it was two sisters who were twins
and they would be on you know how
they're like storefront like my name is
Danny yeah and they were both
prostitutes old
yeah old super all them people pay to
have sex with at the same time I don't
know if at the same time but dude I
don't get that thing to like the [ __ ]
twins like I found the twin Oh make you
know [ __ ] and making out with my
sister yeah I can't do it anyway so then
there's been who else that's the closest
person you know everything about them I
would never have to speculate
you know what Gio does with her sisters
now I don't talk to my sisters thanks
for bringing up that [ __ ] story
uh-huh I'm sorry Gio did you want to
kiss the makeup boy yeah sorry tip
whatever keep boys yeah yeah so this is
norm always names norm norm
this guy's [ __ ] dicks down [ __ ] I
can't imagine that the tulip is like a
metaphor for your lips on his debut nor
tell acute I would never ever want to
protect that guy doesn't have sex clear
and he actually has gay sex okay huge
woody all right then I'm winning get it
in why why did it's because like what in
his youth he was like in church if he
was never able to like explore yeah he
was because he was married for 20 years
woman oh so now he's like doing a now
he's like let's oh why did why were you
judging him before I was judging him
because I was like oh you're just kind
of gross I kind of have 16 girls but now
like he like restricted that I'm in
himself for so long that now he's having
all kinds of games but he's doing it for
porn isn't no he wants to he likes it
this is what norm said he said I was a
campus minister and there was this
parade of men saying that they might be
gay and asking how they'd handle it it
was 1997 when I acknowledged guess what
I'm a gay man so he separated from his
wife in the end up moving in with the
man that he calls his housemate and
that's when like yours I don't know how
how many years passed but he was
eventually asked by a friend if he
wanted to join the porn industry how do
you make that leap see I couldn't you
like leaving your wife and be like I
just realized I'm gay and I can see that
but then going like and I'm gonna do
porn that's the question I don't know
any friends that have ever once asked me
do you wanna do some porn oh yeah how do
you have friends like we're not in that
industry and he is yeah
go Jojo I feel like we're closer to that
industry they literally are video like
that did this video they're gonna go
watch porn that's how close we are I
have a theory maybe it's because it was
so shamed it by the church to be
homosexual that when you came out it's
like I want the world to know that I'm
not scared
like I want as many dicks as I can you
know maybe that's what he thought and I
feel you but I still can't make the
connection of jumping into porn now well
maybe he was like you know how like some
guys are just like so sexually active
like how at 85 girl I mean they're
always sexually do you actually saying
that now at 85 he's way more adventurous
and more vibrant than his 45 year old
self yeah dude senior citizen at homes
they're all [ __ ] I don't know that
you couldn't get it up anymore they have
they have drugs for that he said it it's
as though my erotic energy has taken
over and inhabited me well good for him
but he's suppressive for so long so he's
saying like this is what he said we are
going to have sex anyway so why not make
you make it a liberating and bonding
experience and get paid yeah I can get
away in the shadows yeah if the universe
grants me another 10 years who knows
what will happen what will be happening
with sex dude you know how there's like
old people who get tattoos or like jump
off of airplanes you know some people
join foreign I guess you know cuz adopt
I you're like [ __ ] I'm gonna die like
yeah I'm gonna get on drugs like that
sounds good I just do all the drugs yeah
I'm gonna start now then we're still Lou
young any more ears up so my twenties
okay yes so they're also talking about
this other woman who she's doing porn
like she's doing webcam modeling and she
also is a prostitute because guys come
over and have sex with her
while her husband is in the next room
watching sports cuz he's disabled so he
can't work he had a heart attack all and
he's okay with their unable to say
thanks they're unable to have kind of
disabled Oh cuz of his heart so he's
like you know what get it in were you
bidding he said like it's okay it sucks
but it's okay because like she's
supporting us how heartbreaking
importing our family I wish she was like
she's getting me that money like a pimp
then I feel better you know but he's
like he's like a sad heartbroken all
literally cuz it's hard yeah why can't
she work at a grocery stores as well it
probably doesn't pass well [ __ ] with
your husband next door that's too sad
maybe he needs to take his power back
and be like yeah go get it be SH you
know what I mean like instead of feeling
bad for himself
yeah yeah but it's all a front yeah I
mean it may it's like those girls like I
know
well I follow a couple girls who have
like snapchat premiums and they have
husbands you follow their pee no no I
follow them like on regular social ICSC
no I don't I wouldn't never pay for that
but well like it's just crazy to me cuz
I like my boyfriend can't relate to that
like he would never [ __ ] let me have a
snapchat premium so it's just amazing
how some dudes are like yeah do it like
get his money didn't Joe it Joe would be
like that she will let you yeah he's
like go make us money go pick but like
seriously it sounds like he's [ __ ]
around though like seriously he acts
like he's never jealous about anything
ever and it pisses me off
hmm what he likes
even now did you get an update a recent
update it could be different girl
especially amplified now that the recent
ugly update has been happening so ya
know you he started the account for you
and everything no no no it's just he he
likes it he gets off on the way that guy
mom she likes that other guys like you
damn
go down go off in the comments right now
you guys
[Applause]
Kasey's young yeah so you think he'll be
oh sorry so you think he'll be done with
you having a snapchat preman I think you
would love that don't you mix um why are
you so poor $40 to mommy I don't want it
oh really so you don't care about Isaac
she's on snow right now you're doing it
for Jess jess is like pimping you out to
go to that oh you don't care about your
son show them titties in tears about
Casey's like yeah yeah when you cry and
a good pimp you don't we're gonna see
you with a [ __ ] fur coat isn't gold
to us you should be a dog you should be
a Dom cuz the dogs don't have to do
anything like really sexual and you're
really good really because you could
point out all their flaws and make them
cry and like with them and stuff seen it
happen in life and connect somewhat
connect me with all these guys that want
to get stuff actually I do have a
connect I do every show up and I'm like
or maybe just to tack there's like Dom's
that don't even meet Facebook yeah guys
are done they waste their money on
stupid even though you said that you're
so gonna get it yeah but it's hard to
find a girl like through normal like
circumstances that's also down to do
that yeah that's true
all right sign up guys hit the link
below yeah
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]